- I was 11 years old when I
put myself into foster care.
(slow dramatic music)
It kind of came to a breaking
point around when I turned 11.
There was a lot of physical fights,
there was a lot of just emotional abuse.
I just kept having issues with my dad.
We never got along,
we'd always butt heads,
and then he started dating his cousin
which was a little weird for me.
I ended up calling the Kids Help Phone.
I told them that I was depressed,
that I'm having all
these issues in my home
and that I couldn't take it
anymore and I needed to get out.
Then the police came and
then I got taken away
and put into foster care.
I first went into a girls home.
I feel like we should take
home out of girls home.
My stuff would get stolen all
the time, I would get beat up.
I ended up at a cucumber
farm with Mennonites.
I ended up with a very,
very religious family.
It felt like I was just sort
of an extra in their movie.
I was just like an extra in their life.
I ended up at a bunch of different homes
but I didn't find anything very permanent.
There was really nowhere to go.
I moved out just before I turned 17.
I was in high school and
I was working full time.
I still had a little
bit of monthly support
from the children's aid,
but as soon as I turned 21,
they cut off all benefits.
I lost everything I had.
(slow dramatic music)
You're just starting one of
the biggest parts of your life
and then now you're just shoved
to the side and unimportant.
I remember repeatedly going into
negative in my bank account.
I'd just paid my rent and then
I didn't have any money for food.
I couldn't afford toilet paper.
(upbeat dance music)
I feel like youth who are
aging out of foster care,
they don't have the financial training.
They don't have the emotional support
and it's a no wonder
they're ending up homeless
and they're ending up
not grading high school,
not going to college, not
getting a proper education
and ending up broke.
(upbeat dance music)
What up, foxx family?
I just think that if there's
anyone going through this,
like anyone that's going
through being a youth
that's about to age out of foster care,
that's aging out of foster care,
there is thousands of other people
that are going through
the same thing as you.
You're not alone.
(upbeat dance music)